[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález hoy haremos
foco en colombia este país se prepara
para una importante cita electoral que
está prevista para el domingo 13 de
marzo los colombianos votarán la
renovación de las dos cámaras del
congreso es decir elegirán 108 senadores
que son de circunscripción nacional y
172 representantes a la cámara que son
de circunscripción regional un total de
39 millones de colombianos están
llamados a las urnas para estas
elecciones parlamentarias
estos comicios tienen lugar en un
momento de baja popularidad del congreso
donde hay un alto desinterés por la
política nacional y muchos temas que
molestan a los colombianos como el alza
en el costo de vida también la difícil
reactivación económica del país después
del confinamiento debido a la pandemia
del cobi 19 también el aumento en la
violencia y la desconfianza
institucional sobre todo hacia el senado
pero los colombianos también
participarán en una consulta
interpartidista de tres coaliciones que
busca elegir a un candidato que irá a
disputar las elecciones presidenciales
cada una de estas tres coaliciones busca
su candidato para enfrentarse en las
presidenciales del 29 de mayo estas
primarias de consulta entre coaliciones
han eclipsado las elecciones
parlamentarias y para muchos han venido
a volver digámoslo así muy complejo el
proceso electoral en colombia muchos
colombianos han dicho estar confundidos
con tantas votaciones que van a tener
que hacer el domingo cada coalición
representa un segmento del espectro
político de ese país suramericano
la coalición centro esperanza representa
como su nombre lo dice a partidos de
centro mientras el pacto histórico reúne
formaciones de la izquierda y la
coalición de equipo por colombia
representa a la derecha que es
actualmente la que se encuentra en el
poder en este país suramericano
de estas consultas como les decía
saldrán tres candidatos que se suman a
otros tres que van a disputar la primera
vuelta presidencial que está prevista
para el 29 de mayo pero para eso todavía
falta mucho tiempo ahora nos vamos a
enfocar en las elecciones parlamentarias
está el partido oficialista es decir el
centro democrático en riesgo de perder
la mayoría en el senado como están las
cargas partidarias para conformar este
nuevo legislativo porque los colombianos
tienen en tan mal concepto a esta
institución y quienes podrían salir de
las consultas interpartidistas lo vamos
a analizar hoy aquí en el debate de
france 24 y para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a paola montilla niño
ella es analista y docentes de la
universidad externado de colombia
ella se encuentra en bogotá en la
capital colombiana allí en esta misma
ciudad también se une a esta
conversación patricia muñoz ella es
abogada docente de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales de la
pontificia universidad javeriana ambas
instituciones están ubicadas en la
ciudad de bogotá ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate pueden dejar todos los
comentarios y las preguntas relacionadas
con
a través de las redes sociales pueden
comunicarse con nosotros no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram
también en twitter estamos como france24
bajo ese sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta se la recuerda
el numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios relacionados con
este tema electoral en colombia comienzo
entonces poniendo un poco de contexto de
lo que está sucediendo en colombia
comienzo con paola allí en la ciudad de
bogotá para hola bienvenida al programa
y bueno ya lo decía comencemos por el
contexto cómo llega a colombia a estas
importantes elecciones parlamentarias
que son una previa de lo que van a ser
las presidenciales que están previstas
para mayo un primer semestre del 2022
electoral allí en colombia
santiago pero buenas tardes un gusto
saludarte y también aprovecho para
saludar a patricia con las profesoras a
la cual yo tengo gran cariño y
admiración pues santiago para para
comenzar colombia llega con una
insatisfacción con poca satisfacción
hacia la democracia es así acá se ubican
más o menos hacia el 18 por ciento
también llegamos con moto muy bien como
usted muy bien lo menciona llegamos en
un contexto de alta insatisfacción
social consecuencia de la pandemia con
niveles de empleo muy altos con niveles
de desempleo altos con una pobreza cada
vez más alta pero también adicionalmente
encontramos que 159 municipios aún
permanecen como con presencia de grupos
armados y la mujer ha resaltado que los
mosquitos podrían existir pues algunos
riesgos para estas elecciones de marzo
del próximo 13 de marca entonces creo
que resumiría en esos tres grandes
puntos del panorama de colombia previas
las elecciones del próximo domingo y
patricia bienvenida también al programa
cuáles son sus impresiones entonces de
cómo llega
este país a estas elecciones
parlamentarias que van a ser disputadas
este fin de semana
santiago buenas tardes un caluroso
saludo a la doctora paola a las personas
que nos acompañan en esta emisión en
efecto a las elecciones del próximo 13
de marzo llegamos con una combinación de
esperanza frente a los procesos que
implica el primer la primera gran
elección después de la pandemia después
de las protestas sociales que tuvimos en
el país desde 2018 y que reflejaron
estos altos niveles de inconformidad con
el gobierno mismo pero con las
instituciones y el papel de estas
instituciones es una inconformidad por
los altos niveles de corrupción y la
inquietud frente a lo que estamos
haciendo en la lucha contra la
corrupción unas elecciones el 13 de
marzo que vienen combinadas no sólo para
renovar el congreso tal como usted lo
mencionaba sino tres consultas para
elegir candidatos a la presidencia de la
república unas elecciones en un ambiente
donde la confianza en las instituciones
se ha deteriorado la donde no tenemos
grandes electores en las listas ha
cenado y vamos a tener entonces
muchas expectativas frente a la manera
cómo se relacionan estos elementos el
próximo domingo vamos a analizar varios
de los puntos que ustedes han mencionado
en este panorama jano en general de cómo
está colombia lo mencionaba al inicio de
la introducción tal parece que estas
elecciones del domingo son un proceso
electoral complejo con estas consultas
más las elecciones parlamentarias muchos
colombianos han dicho que no entienden
bien en qué proceso es que están y
ustedes también lo mencionaban hay
varios municipios más de un centenar de
municipios que tienen problemas de
seguridad para el estado colombiano es
muy difícil llegar a ejercer presencia
en todos los rincones de
el país y hay zonas rurales muy
apartadas donde las elecciones van a ser
complicadas colombia siempre ha tenido
estas dificultades de patricia le
pregunta usted para hacer la ronda la
inversa siempre ha tenido dificultades
en estos procesos electorales pese a que
desde fuera de las fronteras se ve como
un país que tiene una democracia
bastante creíble que tiene una alta
satisfacción y garantías para sus
ciudadanos por lo menos así se ve desde
afuera
santiago recordemos que estas serían las
segundas elecciones nacionales después
de la firma del proceso de paz
además hay unas condiciones geográficas
en el país que dificultan una presencia
permanente
del del estado y una
seguridad
permanente para los ciudadanos que se ha
visto deteriorada como lo decía la
doctora paola montilla por el
recrudecimiento de la violencia en
ciertas zonas las expectativas que
generó la firma del acuerdo de paz con
las farc
no necesariamente
acabó con todos los brotes de violencia
algunos generados por otros grupos
alzados en armas recordemos también este
fenómeno de las disidencias después de
la firma del acuerdo de paz
y hay otras situaciones asociadas a
minería ilegal a presencia de actores
ligados al narcotráfico que generan
situaciones de perturbación
al orden público y a la tranquilidad en
las regiones
paola desde su perspectiva el tema de
seguridad que siempre ha sido importante
y destacado para estos procesos
electorales allí
llama la atención también desde fuera de
colombia lo que uno puede ver es que no
hay garantías por ejemplo para algunos
actores sociales para líderes en zonas
apartadas que están garantizadas está la
seguridad para estos comicios
parlamentarios y estas consultas
interpartidistas que va a vivir colombia
en los próximos días
y mira como lo mencionaba la profesora
patricia
digamos en general sintaxis pido esa
tendencia previa a relacionar realmente
con el conflicto de tener ciertos
municipios con un alto riesgo electoral
por factores de violencia sin embargo
también hay que reconocer que
disminuimos aunque sea en menor
porcentaje el número de municipios que
en este momento presentan ese riesgo de
violencia ahora bien también es cierto
que por ejemplo existen municipios y
especialmente aquellos relacionados en
las disposiciones transitorias de paz
donde muchas personas que se están
presentando no han tenido las garantías
para hacer realmente una campaña de
manera libre de poder expresar
libremente su voz en este sentido creo
que en algunas zonas donde estaba
relacionada socias hemos contado
naturalmente con una presidencia del
conflicto pues muy buenas que aún en las
calidades democráticas y esa libre
expresión todavía y esa competencia
política todavía tiene
se perfila como tenue no se perfila como
terna sin embargo creo que también se
han hecho esfuerzos de la registraduría
para garantizar la presencia de las
urnas para garantizar realmente que se
puedan llevar a cabo los comicios
entonces estamos como en un momento en
a la expectativa de tránsito porque
finalmente tenemos mientras se complica
de transitorias de paz que son
importantes pero contamos con líderes
que se están presentando por estas
listas que nos volvió el excel tú eres
su pleno tú eres un pleno derecho así es
que la política no y también sin
mencionar pues ya existen históricos de
asesinato esencial líderes sociales sin
embargo y usted la registraduría han
mantenido y ha hecho y es garante de
quienes los sitios más apartados de
bogotá que puedan garantizando su
elección
paola hablemos de este congreso que
termina funciones que cierra ya estos
cuatro años de funciones en colombia que
legado deja porque pasa a la historia
como este congreso que estuvo en la
legislatura del país durante la pandemia
de kobe 19 también
después de haberse firmado el proceso de
paz de haberse firmado el acuerdo y de
haber puesto en marcha algunos de los
puntos que estaban allí pendientes y de
haber sido parte de un gobierno también
que el presidente no cuenta con mucha
popularidad entre los colombianos qué
legado deja este congreso como cierra
este ciclo y por qué los colombianos no
confían en el congreso y hay tantos
índices de desprestigio de esta
institución
para comenzar nos por varela la
explicación en tonos en dos partes
primero la confianza que se manifiesta
en el congreso colombiano llamó no es
nueva de los últimos cuatro años de
generar el congreso y los varias
instituciones políticas en el país
cuentan con una alta desconfianza una
desconfianza que tampoco es alarmante si
uno lo compara con los niveles de
ustedes confianza que tienen los
concretos en américa latina
ahora respecto a la pregunta puntual
sobre el legado sensible evidentemente
no podemos desconocer que el congreso
colombiano
realmente durante estos dos últimos años
del dibujo mucho su función desde el kit
de marzo el 2020 estamos viendo qué hace
esa emergencia de emergencias sanitarias
que culmina en febrero de 2022 y por
ejemplo algunos estudios como los de la
profesora padrón han mostrado que
durante estos dos años se han sacado o
se han emitido realmente 115 decretos de
ley lo que realmente deja en un segundo
plano lo que podría ser la labor del
congreso sin embargo yo creo que también
hay que resaltar y creo que el mayor
legado sin lugar a dudas de este
congreso fue el acto legislativo que
aprobó las circunscripciones de paz
transitorias de paz creo que es un al
dar todo para el proceso de paz es un
espaldarazo para
en la participación política de colombia
y también yo creo que podríamos
mencionar la ley migratoria que busca
reconocer el derecho de los migrantes y
que también es reconocida a nivel
internacional por muchos países
y patricia algo para complementar sobre
el legado que deja este congreso en
particular haber legislado durante la
pandemia de kobe 19 que afectó
fuertemente a colombia por supuesto le
hicieron frente a esta pandemia como lo
ha hecho el mundo entero con sus altos y
sus bajos pero cuál es el balance que
usted puede hacer de esta legislación
santiago plenamente de acuerdo con la
profesora paola destacar los puntos que
mencionaba
agregaríamos bueno el tema migratorio
que fue abordado por el congreso pero
tendríamos que mencionar las
dificultades que tuvo el congreso para
poder legislar y para poder ponerse en
conexión con las problemáticas
ciudadanas que se que surgieron durante
la pandemia quizás esa dificultad llevó
a que el congreso dejará muchos temas
pendientes
sobre los cuales no pudo legislar los
temas ambientales que generan hoy mucha
preocupación en el país en el continente
y a nivel global y varias reformas a la
justicia
a la reforma política la misma discusión
sobre reforma pensional y sobre todo
santiago la necesidad de poder recuperar
los niveles de confianza en el congreso
y de poder en implementar una lucha
frontal contra el fenómeno de la
corrupción
patricia con este panorama que ustedes
paula nos nos hablan y este resumen de
lo que puede haber sido esta legislatura
en el congreso colombiano esto entonces
llevará a un reequilibrio de las cargas
para la siguiente legislatura todo esto
lo va a decidir por supuesto el pueblo
colombiano a través de las urnas pero
cree usted que va a haber un cambio en
las cargas en cuanto a los partidos
políticos precisamente para tratar de
darle más voz a algunos sectores o
prioridad algunos temas que para los
colombianos son indispensables que
empiecen a moverse allí en el en el
congreso
qué perspectiva tiene usted en cuanto a
ese equilibrio de cargas
si santiago es posible que este panorama
que hemos descrito que
está
esta preocupación de los ciudadanos
frente a las problemáticas que no han
sido resueltas y que se manifestaron a
través de protestas y marchas en los
últimos tres años
lleve a que la el nuevo congreso pueda
traer consigo algunos cambios en el
tamaño de las bancadas en la
representación de los partidos políticos
en el partido de gobierno por ejemplo en
los estudios de opinión que hemos
consultado en los últimos meses tiene
unos mayores niveles de desfavorabilidad
y de rechazo es lo mismo que en los
niveles de aprobación en la gestión del
gobierno ello puede llevar a que
bancadas mayoritarias como la del centro
democrático en la anterior legislatura
puedan ver disminuido el número de
congresistas al igual que partidos
políticos considerados tradicionales
como cambio radical partido conservador
partido liberal
y los partidos que representan el
espectro ideológico del centro y de la
izquierda
y que van en coalición para el el senado
de la república y algunas listas a
cámaras coalición alianza verde pacto
histórico pueden
incrementar su representación a nivel
del senado y a nivel de cámara y es
posible que de los partidos de nuevos
partidos que en esta contienda
inician pues el proceso para entrar al
congreso puedan algunos de ellos tener
éxito
paola desde su perspectiva y tomando en
cuenta lo que dice patricia
históricamente el congreso colombiano ha
tenido más una tendencia digamos
centroderecha podemos decirlo así
estaríamos próximos a encontrarnos con
un congreso que sea un poco más
centroizquierda tomando en cuenta lo que
nos dice patricia o cuál es su análisis
porque la que mencionaste es cierto
realmente el congreso colombiano se ha
destacado por ti es para asia intenta y
centroderecha sin embargo podemos
encontrarnos que los partidos de
izquierda como el polo democrático
alternativo la lista de los decentes en
este momento no presentaron listas al
congreso y todos finalmente se agruparon
bajo la coalición del pacto histórico la
presencia en la lista impacto histórico
sin lugar a dudas de políticos
reconocidos puede aumentar el número de
porcentaje de votos y por ende su
presencia en el congreso sin embargo si
tenemos en cuenta que por ejemplo en el
senado es a esta tendencia o esta
bancada de izquierda en el 2018
representaba el 13 por ciento no llegar
a que cambie radicalmente a tener una
mayoría legislativa
es poco probable en otras palabras puede
aumentar la presencia de la izquierda en
el senado sin lugar a dudas puede
aumentar ese 13% que se presentó las
elecciones del 2008
pero no puede llegar a ser una mayoría
legislativa obtendría pocos podrían
llegar a hacer una mayoría legislativa
porque porque la cámara el panorama es
un poco singular ya este respecto por
ejemplo los partidos de izquierda en la
cámara en el 2018 tenían un 4 por ciento
y de pasar desde el 4 por ciento
aumentará la mayoría legislativa
finalmente pues es un desafío muy alto
en suma yo sí creo que los partidos de
izquierdas acusados todos en el pacto
histórico pueden aumentar el número de
curules pero no
pienso realmente que existe una
probabilidad que se cambia drásticamente
el balance de puertas que ha existido
tradicionalmente en el congreso
colombiano matriz y cuál es su opinión
sobre este tema estamos ante un congreso
colombiano que pueda tener un poco más
presencia de la izquierda y amplió la
pregunta está la democracia y la
sociedad colombiana lista dado del
antecedente histórico que tiene este
país para tener un congreso donde haya
más presencia izquierda donde pueda
darse el escenario de tener una mayoría
para olano no lo vemos así
pero pero si un aumento del número de
curules y tal vez empezar a dar un giro
hacia otro hacia otra tendencia política
como lo ve usted
no en la misma línea de la doctora paula
en la coalición
del pacto histórico y también en la
coalición de centro pueden aumentar el
número de congresistas
no no no creo y aquí comparto el
planteamiento de la profesora paola que
alcancen una mayoría que lleve a
desequilibrar que lleve a a
a generar este desequilibrio al interior
del congreso a favor de la izquierda en
este caso lo que sí es cierto es que
vamos a mantener unas bancadas
medias cercanas en número que obligan
por supuesto a los procesos de coalición
tanto para el ejercicio de apoyo al
gobierno y sacar adelante las
iniciativas desde la bancada de gobierno
como para el ejercicio de la oposición
sea quien ocupe en la fórmula
presidencia y vicepresidencia en las
próximas elecciones coaliciones porque
ningún partido por sí solo va a alcanzar
una mayoría suficiente que le permita
sacar adelante las iniciativas en uno o
en otro sentido pero siendo de alguna no
sé si ustedes comparten esta impresión
ese tipo de ejercicio de formación de
coaliciones para poder tener mayorías
requiere un poco de madurez democrática
y política
y que tanto colombia está en ese
escenario para para juntarse armar
alianzas armar coaliciones vemos mira es
el tema que vamos a hablar a
continuación estas 3 consultas
interpartidistas que son varios partidos
tratando de buscar un líder para
enfrentarse en las presidenciales
patricia muy puntualmente esto eso
entonces es un buen síntoma de la
democracia colombiana que haya necesidad
de negociar de confrontar ideas entre
partidos unirse para buscar mayorías
si es un proceso santiago y yo creo que
las últimas reformas políticas
llevan a este camino a esta necesidad de
la negociación y por supuesto la
aprobación del estatuto de la oposición
la necesidad de que las bancadas se
declaren de gobierno de oposición o
independientes es parte de este proceso
de este paso a paso que estamos dando en
la democracia colombiana para fortalecer
los procesos de coaliciones y acuerdos
interesante ver este punto de vista
sobre todo para las personas que están
fuera de las fronteras colombianas que
no conocen bien el tema político en este
país quiero pasar ahora a paola y
patricia a hablar de estas tres
consultas interpartidistas son
importantes han logrado casi que
eclipsar la importancia de las
elecciones parlamentarias de escoger el
congreso y los representantes a cámara
porque salen tres candidatos que irán a
las presidenciales de mayo como están
conformadas estas coaliciones que ven
ustedes allí que análisis pueden hacer
de estas tres consultas y quiénes son
los candidatos fuertes comenzamos por
paola
muy normalmente este estas consultas han
permitido que se diferencien tres
bloques políticos bastantes no tenemos
prácticamente que yo creo que en este
momento la ciudadanía puede diferenciar
claramente cuáles son los partidos de
derecha de centro y despierta dentro de
los partidos del pacto histórico el
pacto histórico como representante han
dignado de los partidos de izquierda
también te el abanderado y el que lleva
en las mismas intenciones de voto y que
las ha mantenido en constante no
gustavo petro sede común como el ganador
muy posiblemente de la de la consulta
interpartidista al pacto histórico
dentro de la coalición por la del centro
esperanza pues realmente allí se
aglutinan partidos que han mantenido una
postura
neutral frente
apoyando el libre mercado pero también
ir enfatizando en la necesidad que se
tiene en este momento de colombia de
disminuir las desigualdades sociales sin
embargo al interior del pacto de perdón
de la coalición centro esperanza pues
todavía advertirse consenso se han
mantenido algunas disputas por ejemplo
existe conciencia frente a la
legalización de la droga no existe
consenso por ejemplo frente a reformas
no necesarias para la policía
y en este punto la coalición después de
siempre esperanza ha demostrado bastante
escritura allí el candidato que tiene la
mayor intención de voto es sergio
fajardo que fue un pre cantín fue
candidato presidencial para las
elecciones de 2018 y que las últimas
encuestas de intención de voto con lo
colocan como el ganador de la coalición
en el centro de la coalición que centro
y de hecho cuando lo cuando le preguntan
ha lucido anuncia y entra a jugar
como el segundo en que estudia las
puertas desplazando al recuerda
por otra parte en la coalición equipo
colombia que aglutina a los partidos de
derecha realmente que los reúne los
partidos de derecha al igual que la
coalición centro esperanza si bien no se
han mantenido o no se han sido visibles
entre las fisuras que ha tenido la
coalición centre esperanza tampoco
podemos realmente mencionar y asegurar
que existe una coherencia interna
también dentro de la upec a este
candidato se ha demostrado que todavía
existen algunas discrepan y en el campo
de la coalición de esta coalición pues
la persona que está liderando las 53
federico gutiérrez y en segundo lugar el
echar para aumentar en las víctimas
alexa y finalmente también el pueblo que
realmente fue un dato sorprendente las
últimas encuestas que puedan la semana
pasada intención de voto el el
gobernador de boyacá carlos amaya
aumentó no es bastante sí bastantes
puntos en la intención de voto pero por
este momento a las personas que lideran
la coalición la esta coalición es
patricia cuál es el análisis que usted
hace de estas tres consultas
interpartidistas y cómo delinea esto de
cara a esa primera vuelta presidencial
de estos candidatos que se enfrentarán
en el mes de mayo por eso por eso
decíamos que estas elecciones estas
consultas estaban eclipsando las
parlamentarias porque es que se define
cuál va a ser el escenario de las
presidenciales de mayo entonces como
como delinea usted ese panorama político
que análisis hace usted veo que se está
riendo es porque no tiene un buen
análisis
no os santiago en la misma línea de la
profesora paola pero su acertada mirada
frente al proceso nuestro en colombia'
algunos comentarios el primero que esta
práctica de las consultas están
instaladas en otros ejercicios
electorales en el país no se había visto
tanto tan competitiva como lo hemos
visto en estas elecciones tres consultas
claramente organizadas 15 candidatos 3
espectros ideológicos
y por supuesto como usted lo dice voy a
emplear su palabra eclipsar las
elecciones al congreso porque centran la
atención de muchos de los ciudadanos en
el ejercicio presidencial olvidando que
estamos eligiendo
uno de los tres poderes
importantísimos en términos de
representación y otro elemento para para
notar es que
estas consultas de acuerdo a los
estudios de opinión han tenido aquí
diferentes matices la consulta del pacto
histórico con un candidato que como
gustavo petro que ha sacado una ventaja
importante no sólo a sus compañeros de
coalición sino
a los a los candidatos de las
coaliciones restantes en la coalición
centro esperanza que ha tenido que
sortear una serie de tensiones
existe la duda si esta distancia del que
hoy va en punta sergio fajardo es
suficiente con relación al repunte que
han tenido algunos de sus compañeros de
coalición y en particular las
estrategias electorales de alejandro
gaviria que ha recurrido a
recibir una serie de apoyos y
acercamientos de actores políticos de
partidos tradicionales y en el equipo
colombia toca decir que si bien no está
allí el candidato del centro democrático
el candidato del centro democrático
óscar iván zuluaga continuó con su
carrera hacia la presidencia como
independiente el partido ha dejado en
libertad a los seguidores y
muchos se preguntan a quién van a apoyar
estos seguidores pareciendo ser la
figura de federico gutiérrez quien mejor
recoge el apoyo de los militantes y
simpatizantes del centro demócrata que
quedan ya pocos minutos para finalizar
el programa patricia muy puntual quiero
hablar de esas 16 curules de paz un algo
inusual es algo que no es común en otros
países es algo único para colombia hay
mucha controversia al respecto algunos
de los candidatos que aspiraba aspiraban
a esas curules han denunciado han
renunciado a su aspiración han
denunciado también que no han recibido
la financiación necesaria y que en
muchos casos la ciudadanía no sabe ni
cómo tiene que votar estas 16 curules
muy puntual de qué se tratan estas
curules de paz
las 16 orales de las circunscripciones
especiales transitorias de paz
fueron creadas para fortalecer la
representación de las víctimas de
personas que pudiesen llevar la vocería
en las regiones más afectadas más
apartadas que requieren hoy una
presencia institucional fuerte si
queremos realmente llevar la paz a los
territorios por ello estas
circunscripciones sólo se votan en las
zonas rurales las zonas veredales no en
el casco urbano y abarca estos 167
municipios más golpeados por la
violencia de manera histórica el
propósito es que sus voceros que deben
tener condiciones especiales habitantes
de la región víctimas del conflicto
líderes sociales puedan traerse las
voces de la región y podamos llevar
desarrollo y paz pero han tenido los
problemas que la doctora paola
mencionaba y a estos problemas de
seguridad que han llevado a algunos
candidatos a la renuncia yo tendría que
agregar la falta de pedagogía para que
los habitantes de la región sepan que
votamos el domingo y puedan participar
de manera activa me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa quiero hacer
recordar las preguntas que recibí a
través de redes sociales y es
preguntando por la institucionalidad en
colombia qué tan confiables son las
autoridades electorales allí y paola
para el cierre muy puntual antes de
hacer la conclusión con patricia
yo creo que son confiables realmente son
comprables y también en este momento
dentro de la opinión pública existen
algunos
algunos segmentos que están colocando en
cuestión la registraduría nacional pero
realmente en las elecciones y los
veedores internacionales o de elecciones
han demostrado que siguiente existen
algunas falencias relacionadas proyecto
la compra de votos
existe un cliente electoral por materia
de seguridad las autoridades electorales
realmente son confiar con instituciones
confiables a las cuales tendríamos
ninguna certeza
que los
mencione pues se me acaba el tiempo nos
quedan muchos temas para analizar por
supuesto patricia paola les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros habernos
puesto en contexto de cómo está colombia
preparándose para este proceso electoral
importante destacado en este país
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
por estar con nosotros en france 24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]